>> Male presenter: Welcome to Authors at Google
at Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today we welcome author Larry Tye, who will
discuss this latest book Superman: The High
Flying History of America's Most Enduring
Hero.
Larry runs the Boston based Health Coverage
Fellowship which is designed to help the media
do a better job covering critical health care
issues.
Each year it trains ten medical journalists
and newspapers, radio stations and TV outlets
from across the country.
On topics ranging from public health and mental
health to insuring the uninsured.
From 1986 to 2001, Larry was a beat reporter
with the Boston Globe where his primary beat
was medicine.
He also served at the Globe's environmental
reporter, roving national writer, investigative
reporter and sports writer.
And if you look at the Boston Globe archives
you'll see that his byline appeared on over
7,000 articles over 15 years, so I think he
probably doesn't have trouble disciplining
himself to research and writing.
He's the author of five previous books, including
the 2009 New York Times bestseller Satchel:
The Life and Times [clears throat] of an American
Legend.
Which is a biography of two American icons,
the great baseball pitcher Satchel Page, and
Jim Crow, who was the characterization, personification
of the amalgam of racial laws in the south
that mandated the separation of races in all
public spaces.
Without further ado, please give a warm welcome
to Larry Tye.
[Applause]
>> Larry: So other than the camera back there
we should make this really informal.
Small group, we can make this intimate and
the, and I want to tell you a little bit about
what I, why I wrote a book about Superman
and what I found and then we can talk about
it, or we can go enjoy a beautiful day or
do whatever you like.
So where I want to actually start out is saying,
I don't know how much of you know what happens
when you kick off a book.
When you always dream about something big
happening that the, that will lend an event
and some publicity and some oomph to getting
started with a book.
And the, I went to a very strange place, has
anybody ever heard of a town called Metropolis?
There really is a Metropolis.
Anybody know where Metropolis is?
It's in Illinois?
Anybody ever hear, nobody's ever heard of
Metropolis, Illinois.
Well, it's a place so obscure and so unlike
the real Metropolis that we see in the comic
books that to get there from Boston, what
you have to do is take a plane to O'Hare and
then take one of two planes everyday that
are like puddle jumpers that go from O'Hare
airport to Paducah, Kentucky.
And then when you get to Paducah, Kentucky
you have to hope that somebody is there that
will take you the 13 miles across the Ohio
River to the part of Illinois that is more
like the south than anything else in Illinois.
And the, I ended up there, so this is a town
you can get into and you see that not only
doesn't it have an airport or a train station,
it doesn't have a taxi cab or a rental car
company or anything that would give a sense
that it was really a metropolis.
What it has is a big sign saying it is the
official home of Superman.
[Laughter] And it has, on most weekends, when
you get there about 5,000 people.
On the weekend that I went there, the reason
it was the perfect place to kick off my book
was not just because it declares itself the
official home of Superman, but because every
summer, in June, it, that happened to coincide
with the actual weekend my book planned to
come out.
It is the home to the Superman festival, with
30,000 people come from across the world to
celebrate Superman.
So it's like your dream kickoff party.
30,000 [Laughter] of Superman's best friends
from everywhere are there along with all the
crazy press that cares about comic books and
particularly Superman.
And so I went there and I want to just tell
you about one thing that happened to me when
I was there.
I was in a hall, about to give, be a part
of a panel giving a big talk.
And the, it was the biggest hall they had
in Metropolis, which probably seated 300 people.
It was, I guess, a converted, some kind of
theater.
And this hall was about a third full and I'm
there on the panel with two guys who have
played Superboy on TV series.
And we were enough of a draw to fill up a
third of a room.
We get five minutes into our talk and suddenly
this guy walks into the room, a white haired
guy with an ancient white haired lady on his
arm, looking like, if he'd let go of her,
she might tumble down.
And she goes and takes a seat up front but
doesn't say a word.
And within about five minutes between text
messages and cell phone calls, the hall that
was a third full became overflowing and it
was overflowing because this was the woman,
anybody ever hear of somebody named Noel Neill?
>> Male presenter: Yeah.
>> Larry: Who was Noel Neill?
>> Male presenter: She played Lois Lane in
the '50s TV series.
>> Larry: She did.
For all but one year, for all but the first
year in the TV series she was Lois Lane.
There was something even worse in terms of
production value before the TV series there
were, you're all much too young to remember
something called the movie serials.
But the movie serials were these shorts that
lasted 15 minutes.
And on a Saturday afternoon most of America,
every kid in America, wanted to go to the
movies.
And their parents thought they were going
to the movies to see Pride and Prejudice.
They were really going there to see the 15
minute Superman serial that preceded Pride
and Prejudice.
And these were terrible things.
If you've ever heard of the expression cliff
hanger?
Well, a cliffhanger came from these movie
serials because at the end of every serial,
the heroine would be on a railroad track with
the train about to run her over.
[Laughter] And it would end with the train
coming right to her.
And it was a cliffhanger because it wanted
you to come back the next week for the next
episode for a dozen episodes in the serial.
And the best of all the serials was Superman
and Noel Niell was there.
There were two people who made my day in Metropolis.
One was Noel Niell and the other one was,
I brought you a little picture to show you
who my other favorite guy there was in Metropolis.
And that's me and that is the biggest Superman
in the world.
[Laughter] 15 feet high and it is made of
bronze and this, I don't know if anybody reads
ever the Boston Globe, but this picture, this
crazy picture was in the Globe travel section,
me describing in the Sunday's Globe, in yesterday's
Globe, my trip to Metropolis.
And he is made of bronze for one reason, he
was initially, Metropolis decided in it's
three block long downtown that the only thing
the official home of Superman could have,
it had to have a big statue of Superman looking
down the street towards downtown.
The problem with the original statue was that
he was made of fiberglass.
Now these are people in a town that is very
southern.
And when Superman is made of fiberglass everybody
in town who has a gun --which was everybody
in town-- had to see whether Superman was
in fact bulletproof.
[laughter] And it turned out the fiberglass
Superman was not bullet proof.
So that became a bulletproof riddled statue
of Superman and this is what we got instead.
And this statue has got many attempts to shoot
at him but he is made of bronze and it just
bounces right off like it's supposed to.
If you ever saw the original TV Superman series.
Did you, anybody ever watch reruns that black
and white TV series?
There's something very strange that goes on
there.
And what is strange is Superman is bullet
proof and you watch people shooting at him
and the bullets bounce off.
But when they get frustrated they throw their
gun at him and he ducks.
[laughter] [inaudible] Superman.
So what I want to do is take you for a minute
from Metropolis to my book.
And the obvious question if you see a book
there and you see somebody who has spent their
life being a newspaper reporter and written
books about serious topics like racial segregation
is, why would you write a book about somebody
like Superman.
And I wrote the book partly for a very serious
reason.
I was fascinated, having written books, biographies
before on what I think of as American heroes
and being in the process now of writing a
new biography on my hero growing up, who was
a guy named Bobby Kennedy.
I was intrigued why America embraced the heroes
we do.
What is it that the hero tells us about them
and about ourselves that we think certain
people are heroes?
Today, in today's world politicians last as
heroes for about 15 seconds.
When Barack Obama ran for senator from Illinois,
he posed next to this Superman statue in what
may be the most famous picture on the internet
of Barack Obama.
If you Google, of course Google, the, if you
Google Barack Obama and Superman you will
see a picture of him and the statue that became
widely circulated during his 2008 campaigning
for president.
But from Barack Obama to Michael Jordan to
whomever are our hero is today, they don't
seem to last long.
And Superman has lasted for 74 years and so
I thought a good way to look at heroes was
to look at the guy who maybe the longest,
you see it there, OK great, look at the longest
lasting hero of the last century who is Superman.
So that was a serious reason for writing this
book.
The real reason, the other and maybe more
important reason was I wanted to be ten years
old again.
And for the last year, for the last two years,
be able to call Superman my work, let me be
ten years old.
What I want to do, anybody here grow up as
a Superman fan?
Sort of sort of, yeah, metza metz, no, nobody.
Well the, so I also wanted to see what there
was to find out about Superman, the serious
stuff about the hero part, but also whether
there were new things that I could find out
that even the most avid Superman fan wouldn't
know.
And I just came back from a place called Comic-Con.
Anybody know what Comic-Con is?
Comic-Con is from San Diego, where every year
150,000 very crazy people [laughter] go to
San Diego.
And the only way I can describe to anybody
who hasn't been to Comic-Con what it's like
is, if you have ever been in Times Square
on New Years Eve and you see a million people
packed sort of cheek by jowl and yet they
all look like they're having fun.
They, they for anybody who is claustrophobic,
you'd think it would be a nightmare, but people
are having fun.
150,000 fans at Comic-Con for an entire four
days look like they are having a blast.
80% of them are dressed up in some crazy costume
and they are in a San Diego summer walking
around with incredible stuff on them, must
make them feel like it's 200 degrees, but
they are having a blast.
And I wanted to be able to tell them, even
the craziest Superman fans, things that the
character that they didn't know.
And I want to just tell you a couple of those
things I found out about Superman.
One is, his creator, do we know who created
Superman, who wrote the first Superman story?
>> Male #1: Siegel?
[inaudible]
>> Larry: Jerry Siegel, Jerry Siegel, so we've
speculated for 74 years what Jerry Siegel
was thinking.
he would give short interviews but in the
process of writing this book I came across
Jerry Siegel's unpublished hundred page memoir
where he told us precisely what he was thinking,
why he created the character.
And the reason he created the character is
because Jerry Siegel when he was growing up
in a section of Cleveland, Ohio called Glenville,
a section that was very poor and 95% Jewish.
Jerry Siegel was a little bit too short and
little bit too round and wore glasses that
were a little bit too thick and everyday when
he would go to school, particularly when he
would go out on the playground at recess time,
kids would taunt him.
He was, in the classic sense, a kid who was
bullied.
And they'd come up to him and they'd say "Siegel
Siegel, birds of an eagle."
Now I have no idea what that means, other
than that if you are a 15 year old or a 12
year old kid, you'd wish you could fly away,
because everybody's watching, particularly
all the girls that were watching him and he
was incredibly embarrassed.
And so every night when he would go to bed
he would take a pad of paper and a pencil
and he would draw a world and imagine a world
that would take him away from his real world
of being bullied.
And he created a character to start with that
was called The Super hyphen Man.
And this was a character who was a really
bad guy who wanted to take over the world
the way that Jerry wished that he could've
done and basically, you know, pummel all of
his kids who were bullying him everyday and
that was sort of every kid's reaction, normal
reaction, that you want to be stronger than
everybody else and do them harm if that's
what it takes to sort of to get free of that
bullying.
And that was the way the character looked
until at age 17, something traumatic happened
to Jerry Siegel.
His dad owned a used clothing store in a part
of Cleveland that was sort of a rough neighborhood.
And one day three guys come into that clothing
store and they try on a suit and they walk
out without paying.
And Michael Siegel starts to go after them
and, on the spot, he has a massive heart attack
and he basically drops dead.
And at age 17 this kid, Jerry, who is the
youngest of six siblings of Lithuanian Jewish
immigrant parents, is suddenly bereft.
He has lost his dad, he has lost his hero.
And shortly after that, when he goes to bed
at night with his pad of paper and his pencil,
the character Superman is transformed.
He drops the 'the', he drops the hyphen and
he drops the bad guy act.
And in this story that Jerry Siegel writes,
the first story he writes in this new Superman
character, he runs over the next morning after
finishing his story to his buddy and his neighbor
Joe Shuster's home.
And Joe Shuster is an artist teenage nerd.
And Joe Shuster in his first rendition of
the Superman character draws a guy who is
speeding in to save a man who is being robbed
who looks suspiciously like Michael Siegel.
So what Superman really is, from the very
beginning is a story of a little boy fighting
back against a world that seems kind of cruel
to him.
Only something magical happens that the moment
that Jerry Siegel and Joe Shuster develop
their character, America is at a moment when
it needs a hero maybe more than it ever has
in its history.
We are, in 1938 when the first Superman story
comes out, we're in the middle of what?
>> Male #2: Depression.
>> Larry: The Great Depression.
We're now in the middle of a some other depression
but this was the Great Depression, the one
that seemed to last forever.
We're also on the eve of being dragged into
a war in Europe.
And we're basically a country that's not quite
sure where we're going.
And we need a hero and Jerry Shus, Joe Shuster
and Jerry Siegel give us a hero in a magical
moment that guarantees that starting from
that very first issue in June 1938, basically
every time Superman's on the cover of DC comics
he sold out.
And he sold out in numbers in hundreds of
thousands and close to a million numbers that
comic books have never seen happen, they were
a new medium and this was unheard of.
So the first story I wanted to tell you about
Superman is, that it all starts like everything
with really human scale story and in this
case a bullied boy named Jerry.
The other story I want to tell you about Superman.
Anybody have any idea what religion Superman
is?
Why would Superman have a religion?
How would we even know about his religion?
Well, I want to tell you that every religion
out there has embraced Superman as theirs.
Christians see Superman as the perfect Christ
story.
God sends His only son to earth to show mankind
that it could better than it thought it could
be, and to raise the standards and to raise
the hope of mankind.
Buddhists see Superman as the perfect Zen
character.
Who could be more Zen than Superman who knows
right from wrong and just doesn't even have
to think about any of this?
Atheists and agnostics see Superman as a secular
messiah.
Who needs religion?
Superman knows right from wrong and it's not
about religion.
Well, I'm here to tell you what Superman's
real religion is and Superman is Jewish.
And I want to tell you why I think Superman
is Jewish.
Anybody know what Superman's name was when
he came down from Krypton?
>> Group: Kal-El
>> Larry: Kal-El.
Anybody speak Hebrew here?
Little bit.
What does El mean?
Do you know what El means?
>> Male #3: God
>> Larry: El means God.
Kal means, Kal-El suggests the vessel or voice
of God.
Accidental?
Maybe.
I don't think anything is accidental.
When you grow up in a world that's 95% Jewish
and all of this is part of what Jerry Siegel
told us in his memoir that he was doing which
is writing about what he knows.
I don't think it's an accident.
But if that was an accident, as much as Superman
might look like the Christ story, there's
a better story, there's an even more compelling
metaphor that I think Superman is playing
out.
And this is a story of parents trying to save
their child by floating him out to space to
a river [audience member chuckles] and he's
adopted by two of the most extraordinary gentiles
that the world has ever seen which are John
and Martha Kent in the middle of Kansas.
And they raise the child as their own and
suddenly discover this child is really somebody
exceptional.
Now if that's not the story of Moses in Exodus
then I don't know what the story of Exodus
is.
There are in my book, I go through 20 other
pieces of little hints that Jerry and Joe
left us, but to me the most fun is any name
that ends in the word 'm-a-n', man, is one
of two things: it is either a super hero or
a Jew or in this case both.
So it's not Superman, its Superman.
So one more thing I really want to tell you
here now which is the question that I started
the whole book process with, which is what
is Superman, is there a serious story in Superman?
Anybody who spends a year or two writing a
biography and any publisher who's going to
publish a biography, a serious publisher like
Random House, publishes it only if the book
is a lens into something bigger than just
the story of a comic book character.
And to me I think there are two reasons that
we could learn as to why Superman has survived
for nearly 75 years.
Next summer, you will be bombarded with Superman
stuff.
There will be a movie out and there will be
a million celebrations of Superman's seventy
fifth birthday.
And everybody will be asking, "How has he
managed to last for so long?
When our heroes today disappear in 15 minutes?"
And I think there are two reasons that he
has.
One is that he has evolved more than the fruit
fly, that every generation has gotten a Superman
that is specific to what their particular
needs and aspirations are.
In the 1930s, we were a country, in the 1930s,
we were a country, we were a country on the
eve of war in the middle of a depression and
we got a Superman who was the consummate New
Deal liberal.
He was going out trying to chase down slum
lords and wife beaters and he never told us
how he voted but we all knew he voted for
Franklin Roosevelt and the whole idea of social
change in America.
Because that was what we needed then.
In the 1940s, when we were going to war, we
need a different kind of hero.
And Superman took us to war in a very interesting
way.
You remember, anybody remember whether Superman
ever actually went to war?
Well, DC comics was really worried about.
They were worried that if they sent Superman
off to war, that people would say "He could
win the war in 15 minutes.
He'd just take over and he'd crush the Nazis
and he'd win the war."
And that would be disparaging the efforts
of our real soldiers who were going over and
being wounded and killed overseas.
So what they did in a brilliant comic book
was, they had Clark Kent go in and do his
induction exam and we all know that every
induction exam, you have to read an eye chart.
And he was looking at the eye chart, only
instead of reading that eye chart, he was
reading an eye chart two examining rooms in
because he had x-ray vision.
[laughter] And he failed his eye test and
this was a particularly compelling explanation
for Joe Shuster who had terrible eye sight
and who was drawing Superman.
He failed his eye test and that meant that
he had to stay home.
And what he ended up doing with Superman throughout
the war years, was he ended up chasing down
saboteurs and protecting us on the home front
and for the government, anytime they did a
war bond drive or were trying to collect metals
or newspapers or anything precious to the
war effort, Superman was out there on their
posters as the centerpiece of their drive.
Every ration kit that went overseas to one
of our troops included a comic book and most
of the time it was a Superman comic book.
So he was out there making soldiers feel like
there was still a little escape from their
horrible world.
And they could read about Superman, he was
making people at home feel patriotic in buying
their war bonds and he was giving America
precisely the hero that we needed in the 1940s.
In the 1950s what was our preoccupation?
>> Male #4: Communism.
>> Larry: Communism.
The red menace.
Superman was out there chasing down the red
menace.
In the 1960s, when we were exploring all kinds
of new avenues, Superman, for part of that
time, was consciously divorced from that.
There was guy named Mort Weisinger who in
the 1960s created what were known as imaginary
stories as if Superman in concept wasn't himself
an imaginary story.
And Superman would get married, or he'd die,
or he'd do all these things and at the end
of the comic book, they would say "Oh, by
the way, this was an imaginary story."
And it probably didn't happen and next comic
book, he won't be married again.
In the 1970s and 80s and 90s, he continued
to do that he continued to give us precisely
what we needed for that era.
So part of the reason I think he survived
forever, is that he evolved, he changed with
our times.
The other reasons is precisely the opposite.
Is that the most important core elements of
Superman maintained themselves around all
of this time, through all those changes.
And that was most importantly the Dudley Do-Right
guy who knows exactly the difference between
right and wrong and never wavers in his choice.
The world had lots of dark heroes like Batman.
The world had lots of fraught and anxious
heroes like Spiderman, but there was one guy
who was always out there when we needed some
sense of right and wrong, Superman was out
there as clunky as that might have seemed
it also to kids and their parents and their
grandparents that seemed familiar enough,
that Superman was always there as the touchstone
for a certain kind of righteous hero in America.
And I think those two capacities put together
all but gave us a character that has survived
for nearly 75 years and if the lawyers and
the heirs to Superman who are doing battle
over his rights right now don't screw it up,
he'll be around for another 75 years.
What I think I would like to do here is actually
stop and see if we wanted to questions, discussion
or anything?
Yeah?
>> Male #5: So you mentioned that we're coming
up on the 75th anniversary, what was the timing
of this book, why not wait a little longer
so you can really pick up on that [inaudible].
>> Larry: For me the timing of it.
Oh it was two things.
One is, I'll be candid with you that the timing
was partly the movie was due out this summer
and I thought it was really good timing to
have it just when the movie was coming out.
Imagine if you had a history of Batman out
at this moment you would be there interviewed
by a million people.
Well, in fact it turned out to be kind of
brilliant timing accidental that this is the
summer of the superhero in America.
We had the Avengers, we had Batman, we had
Spiderman, and we even had an animated Superman
called Superman versus the Elite.
So the timing has been great and your dream
as an author, there are certain touchstones
today and the world minus Oprah's book club,
there are the biggest thing that you can have
happen.
It used to be that if you were on Oprah the
next day every bookstore in America would
sell out because she said "Buy the book."
In an Oprah-less world, what you want to do
is, New York Times is the touchstone in terms
of newspapers and this was the cover review
a few weeks ago [baby giggles]
>>male #6: sorry
>>Larry Tye: in the the New York Times and
I'm convinced it was partly due to with the
fact this was the summer of the super hero.
And it was also to do with the fact that when
they look through all the reviews that they
could put on a cover, who could be a more
compelling visual image than they had this
brilliant drawing of Superman, you know, flying
across the cover of the book review.
So the timing was, turned out to be good for
lots of reasons.
The other golden thing if you want to sell
a book, is there is one person, radio it turns
out sells books better than any media.
There is one person in radio, I don't know
if anybody is an NPR person, but Terry Gross
is the closest thing to Oprah.
And if you are, can I use the word Amazon
in here, with Google?
If you are number 20,000 on Amazon's best
seller list before Terry Gross airs your interview,
we watched my book became one of what Amazon
called their ten movers and shakers, meaning
in the course of a day it moved more numbers
up the list and it was just because of Terry
Gross.
But the other thing that I realized is, if
the book had come out next summer on the 75th
anniversary, I guarantee you that there are
ten other books in the works on Superman timed
for his 75th, so you actually want to be the
definitive one that we sell before and then
your paperback comes out a year later [laughter]
and the paperback will come out just in time
for that.
But the, but I actually at the end of this
I have a question for all you Google experts
on books.
Anything else on Superman?
>> Male #7: I'm curious if if Kavalier and
Clay was sort of loosely inspired by Siegel
and Shuster, was something that was in here
[unintelligible], was like somebody that he
talks to about
>> Larry: If you haven't, if you don't know
who Michael Schiavone is, there is only one
thing you should know about Michael Schiavone,
there's only one book, he's written a lot
of good books, but there's only one book that
rises above everything and that's Kavalier
and Clay.
And that is a book about two fictional comic
book creators.
That as you say is really Jerry Siegel and
Joe Shuster and it is a book that is so good
that the nicest thing I could ever say about
a book is when I got near the end, I would
ration myself a certain number of pages to
read every night because I didn't want the
book to end, it was really brilliant.
And so my goal was to write a book a non-fiction
that drew on the same rich story he did in
fiction and while they call these things on
the back of the book blurbs and the guy who
was the executive producer of the big Batman
movies and taught the first course, ever,
on comic books, said a nice thing which is
not true, but a nice thing, he said, "If you
like reading the amazing adventures of Kavalier
and Clay, wait till you read Larry Tye's true
story behind it all."
That's sort of the dream kind of thing that
you want somebody, because this was the book
that was really brilliant.
But the great thing that I found out was that
the only thing better than writing brilliant
fiction is to find a non-fiction story that
reads like fiction and Jerry and Joe's story
and Superman's story, if you can't write a
good non-fiction book about that then shame
on you because the story is incredibly rich,
it has 75 years in it.
>> Male #8: So were you a Superman fan [inaudible]
>> Larry: So I grew up as a, so there are
a million incarnations of Superman, there
are all the various incarnations in the comic
books depending on who is writing it, or who
is drawing it.
There are various TV shows.
There are, you know, I didn't know until I
started writing this book, I'm embarrassed
to say about this whole generation that had
grown up with Smallville as their version
of who Superman was.
And then the Superman coming of age story
that's made it through nine seasons of television.
I grew up as a Superman fan starting with
the TV series and in the 1950s TV series,
if you could believe that this was a Superman
that was played by a guy named George Reeves,
who in his incarnation as Superman, looked
exactly like his incarnations of Clark Kent
minus the glasses.
Who acted, who had no clue how to change his
persona, how to change his voice, his flying
was jumping off a trampoline through a window
and then having a crane hold him up in the
air and it looked about as much like flying
as if somebody held me up in the air and you
whooshed by with a lot of fans blowing and
tried to make it look.
And yet I believed he was Superman because
I wanted to believe, I wanted the character
to be real and I was ten years old.
And yes, I was a fan and I was a fan, I'm
saying, back in the days when Superman was
so crude that if you were willing to buy into
it all you had a pretty good story.
By the 1970s people who met with Christopher
Reeve in those Superman movies, by the 1970s
their motto, their marketing line when they
were marketing those four Christopher Reeve
movies was, "You will believe a man can fly."
And you did believe it.
And by the time we get to the 2013 Man of
Steel story, in the short 30 second blurb
that we saw in the Batman movie, it looked
like he was flying to meet him, it was just
really now you can do a million things.
But in those early days it was the story that
kept us riveted because all the technology
looked so miserable.
[Laughter] Yes, I grew up as a fan and I grew
up even more just fascinated by, the only
two symbols of American popular culture that
you can go anywhere in the world today and
not have to tell people who they are, there
are only two of them and one is obviously
I think Superman the other one is
>> Group: McDonald's
>> Larry: Say again?
McDonalds no, that's good, McDonalds not popular
culture.
Those are, those are products, popular culture
is figures.
Who else in popular culture?
>> Male #9: Mickey Mouse
>> Larry: Mickey Mouse exactly.
Sadly it's Mickey Mouse.
The I thought when I was out posting ads on
the Superman sites asking people when I started
the book to send me their Superman stories;
I thought I'd hear from people from across
America.
I heard from people in Paris, in Buenos Aires
and across Asia and Africa and the, I didn't
realize until I started doing my research
that even in the earliest days he was translated
into more than 50 languages, you know by the
1940s and 50s and today the guy who made Superman
fly in the Christopher Reeve movies was
a guy who grew up in Serbia reading comic
books, Superman comic books translated into
Serbian and that's how he became a fan and
came here and made Superman fly.
It's such a compelling story that it works
everywhere.
>> Male #9: So can you tell how Superman appears
in this series of superhero that characterize
comics, what was before and what happened
after?
>> Larry: Good question.
Before was Superman was based on things that
go back as far as Hercules and Samson and
more immediately he was based on characters
that probably none of you have ever heard
of called Doc Savage, you ever heard of Doc
Savage.
Well, so Doc Savage had everything from a
fortress of solitude that he escaped to, Doc
Savage didn't like women, Doc Savage had a
nickname, called the Man of Bronze and Superman
was the Man of Steel.
He came from a lot of characters that Jerry
was reading in those days.
Doc Savage was one, the Phantom was another,
the Shadow was another, these were early characters
that were not comic books because we didn't
have comic books then, they were comic strips.
The big thing was newspaper comic strips and
that's what Jerry and Joe wrote Superman to
be, only they were just starting this new
medium of having original stories appear in
a booklet form and he was it was on his back,
his muscle bound back, that comic books as
a medium and the whole superhero idea really
took off.
And today nobody reads, we just had a movie
that was modestly successful based on one
of the Superman models which was John Carter
of Mars, did anybody see that movie?
I mean, basically most of those other guys
aren't around today and there's something
magical about the fact that Superman still
is and that his brother in DC comics, Batman,
who came out a year later and Jerry thought
was a clear rip off of the whole Superman
idea and Spiderman, who was the a guy, so
it was one of the other Jewish elements of
the Superman story is that all the early comic
book creators, from Jerry and Joe to the people
who created Batman to the Spiderman creator
were all Jews and they were all Jews for a
very simple reason, that in those days in
the 1930s and early 40s smart Jewish kids
who had thought about going into a world as
a writer, they couldn't get hired because
of antisemitism in the big magazines, they
couldn't get hired in the big ad agencies
and so what they did was, they went to work
doing the lowest grade and the lowest paying
to start with of all the medium which was
comic books.
And a guy named Stanley Lieber a smart Jewish
kid from New York, from the same high school
that half of these kids came from, decided
that he was someday going to write the great
American novel and he was going to write that
under his real name Stanley Lieber.
But in the meantime he had to earn a buck.
And so he would change his name to Stan Lee
and he would go out there and for a year or
two he'd write comic books.
Well, he's still writing comic books 50 years
later and nobody knows that he's called Stanley
Lieber and he never wrote the great American
novel, but he wrote the perfect, I had two
funny interviews with Stan Lee.
With him initially denying that that Spiderman
had anything to do with Superman and finally
admitting this was the anti-Superman.
Superman was the guy who knew instinctively
right from wrong and Spiderman was the guy
who had to sit there and worry about what's
right and what's wrong.
Who do I come from, what's going on?
And unlike Batman or Spiderman or most of
our heroes, there's something about Superman
that in his basic story is incredibly different.
And that is that the real character in Spiderman
is Peter Parker, the real character in Batman
is
>>Male #10: Bruce Wayne
>> Larry: Bruce Wayne.
The real character in Superman is Superman
and his disguise is Clark Kent and what I
think that was all about was that the real
character came from Krypton and he had to
be Superman.
And that was who he was and that was what
he was comfortable as.
And he was trying to understand this new alien
world called mankind that he had dropped into.
And his way of reaching out to mankind was
to take on the identity of a real person and
the identity that he picked, everybody's developed
a million explanations for why he used a reporter
and that was because he could be out there
when news was happening, where damsels needed
rescuing, where murder was.
[audience chuckles] I think that's all garbage,
I think the real reason was Jerry Siegel had
dreamed about being a reporter in his earliest
days and it all goes back to that little boy
and what he wanted to do.
And he dreamed about it and so he made his
hero a reporter in the real world.
And what he was doing is, Jerry and Joe both
said that when they were trying to envision
what Superman looked like they would look
in front of a mirror and they believed that
for anybody who was smart enough if they looked
into them they wouldn't see the schlubby Clark
Kent exterior they would see into their soul
and see that they were really supermen in
disguise and that's something we could all
relate to.
I hope when you look at me up here, you don't
see the balding aging guy, you know with,
you look and see I'm a Superman.
We all dream of that, and I think that's one
of the elemental reasons why Superman is still
going 74 years later.
>> Male #11: So you hinted at that there,
I remember Tarantino, I think, had the whole
dialogue and that the whole monologue, which
was you know, Superman is Superman, Clark
Kent is Superman's comment on mankind.
But he goes a step further to say you know,
he, Clark Kent is weak, you know, he is a
coward, he is all these negative things and
kind of stuff.
I mean, do you see any of that in the, in
kind of Jerry's, can you kind of project from
that?
>> Larry: I would love, I love playing Kent
to Tarantino but I think that the and I think
that Jerry was clearly trying to give Superman
certain, I mean give Clark Kent certain obviously
weaknesses, but I also think the key was not
who Clark Kent was as an exterior.
It was who he was inside and what Jerry was
telling us is that we had to be smarter than
Quentin Tarantino and look beyond that.
And so I spent endless time, probably crazy
wasted time but it was fun watching every
movie that Superman was ever mentioned in.
And watching ever episode of Seinfeld, because
Jerry Seinfeld was obsessed with Superman,
that was his, you know, ultimate hero and
the and I now know more about that trivia
and if I'm ever playing a Trivial Pursuits
game I'll win hands down, but that's about
all it's useful for.
But the, it really is interesting.
Everybody, I was really interested in why
Quentin Tarantino cared about Superman at
all.
And so I tried to interview by many famous
people.
I was also intrigued by, Superman was, over
time about the the most white bread comic
book character ever and we, he was the last
of the characters and his was the last of
the books to try to have any diversity in
his comic book.
And I was intrigued by talking to people like,
Henry Louis Gates, Skip Gates and Al Roker
and lots of prominent African Americans why
they grew up as passionate Superman people.
And it was intriguing.
Their answers were pretty consistently, number
one, most of the heroes when these guys were
growing up were pretty white bread and number
two is, they looked at him as not as this
white guy that I might've looked at him as,
they looked at him as an alien, an outsider
and somebody they could relate to in terms
of their feelings of belonging and not belonging.
And people had come up with the smartest answers
and I wish that I could've written an entire
book just about interesting Superman fans,
interesting answers in why they were fans.
And some of them made me cry when I would
hear people you know talk about how a kid,
a Latino guy who grew up with as he said "No
male role model."
All the men had disappeared from his life
and trying to sort of A, survive and B, thrive
in a ghetto that he grew up in.
And said Superman was his male role model.
And it just, people have weird relationships
to their heroes and it's more than just sort
of a distraction for a lot of people.
So I grew up really touched by it all.
What I should do is actually if you have any
more questions, it's not; we should probably
end this with my being able to ask all of
you a question.
And my question is, so one of the things that
every author is perplexed by, one of the thing
Jonathan and I were talking about, when you
sell a book these days, I don't know if any
of you know what it takes to sell a book to
a publisher.
But what it used to be when I started writing
books ten or twelve years ago you would go
to New York which is where most of the publishers
are and your agent would set up meetings and
you'd sit in a room with you and a couple
of smart editors talking about the substance
of the book and what would the book look like
and when could you deliver and all of this
stuff.
Today when you go and try and sell a book,
you sit in a room with ten or twelve people
and, at best, half of them and sometimes less
are actually the people who have anything
to do with the substance of the book and the
rest are who, who do you think the rest of
them are?
>> Male #12: Venture Capitalists?
>> Larry: Good guess!
They're the book publishing version of adventure
capitalist.
They're marketing people and they want to
see, not can you write a good a book, but
can you go out and sell it, can you talk on
Terry Gross and on Oprah and can you talk
to newspaper reporters to they can write up
and coming story.
They really want to see that you know how
to sell a book.
Well, that's interesting and that sort of
makes sense because most books don't even
earn back the advance you are paid in writing
it and so they want to see if they get a little
bit ahead of that curve.
But the truth is they have no idea in publishing
houses how to sell books.
And they have now, at Random House, and my
publisher is the biggest trade press in America
random house all these lots of other presses
and you're owned by a big company called Bertelsmann
in Europe and they have a department now called
social media, social media's part of the marketing
department.
They have no clue what to do [inaudible].
All they know is they'll ask if you have a
Twitter account and do you have, but they
really have no idea, you can set up a website.
What I want to know is, I'm intrigued by,
so every night I get a, my Google alert on
anywhere my book has been mentioned in the
24 hours since then and it will tell me all
these obscure websites that have said something
about it.
Is there, if you were me and my editor is
the smartest marketing person I've ever met
at a publishing house and what he says is,
"The way you sell a book, is you create buzz."
And he says, "None of us have any clue how
to create buzz so therefore you try everything."
You try old fashioned media like the New York
Times and you try radio, you try TV and you
try a million crazy websites that are out
there talking perpetually about comic books
and about Superman.
But the thing that matters the most in any
of this is your Google world.
How would, is there something that you would
recommend to an author like me that you do
in terms of making Google somehow pay more
attention when anybody asks about Superman
to my Superman version.
Or what would you, what would you do if you
were all writing in your other life when you
leave here at whatever time you leave here
and you were writing your great American novel
and you headed out there and you were trying
to sell it, what would you do in terms of
taking all the knowledge you have about how
this world of social media works and use it
to try to get people to pay attention to your
little thing, your book?
>> Male #13: Could you get involved in some
crazy scandal?
[Laughter]
>> Larry: That's brilliant.
That is brilliant.
My first book ever was a biography named Edward
L. Bernays.
And his moniker when he died and the New York
Times ran a full page a full page obituary
on him, nobody's probably ever heard of Edward
L. Bernays.
Well he was called the father of public relations.
He was Sigmund Freud's double nephew, brother
and sister married brother and sister and
so, he took his favorite uncle's ideas on
why people behaved the way they do and used
it on behalf of everybody from General Electric
and General Motors to presidential candidates
to lots of other people and he said, "It doesn't
matter what they say about you as long as
they spell your name right."
[laughter] He would try himself into a scandal
or into good news or whatever it was, but
short of creating a scandal you know, whether
they--.
The Batman film producers were doing the million,
you know, 'we feel terribles' about the horrible
thing that happened in Colorado the weekend
that Batman came out.
And yet look a week later and you see it was
the second biggest selling movie in the history
of movies that weekend and being linked to
that scandal, which I felt could kill the
movie, in fact, everybody in America was talking
on the talk shows and everywhere else about
Batman and everybody had to go see what the
talk was all about.
And I think one of the factors aside from
good marketing [inaudible] was being tied
to a horrible tragedy.
But what would you do, seriously, [laughter]
you're around all these brilliant Google people.
>> Male #14: Seriously, I think probably none
of us actually work on the search work here,
but I from what I know about search, I think
the canonical answer is, you can't.
There's-
>> Male #15: That's not the canonical answer.
[inaudible]
>> Male #14: Because organics buzz right?
>> Larry: So you're saying how to get enough
links to your website or whatever.
>> Male #15: That's how Google works.
>> Larry: But what, I'm sorry, let me rephrase
my question.
Using, not just as you're Google hat, but
your being smart people who are out there
in this new world of social media you should
all be telling Random House social media department
what to do.
What would you do in terms of just generally
trying to get up some interest in Superman?
[laughter]
>> Male #16: I'm actually in my free time
trying to write a book about angels and demons
battling and stuff.
And my thought was it would be really cool,
and it would probably be relatively cheap
to have like I'm kind of going down the YouTube
route, like, if you had Superman fly in from
like the top of a building or something and
start handing out like discounts for books
at the store, [laughter] there'd probably
be a lot of people like filming that with
their phone and like you could actually put
some press around it and the local news would
probably pick it up.
But that would be interesting like.
>> Larry: So create something that's so compelling,
that's cool enough.
[Inaudible]
>> Male #16: That it gets viral and like people
start talking about it.
But then you got to tie it into the book somehow,
like they and then maybe you get the local
news interview or something like that.
>> Larry: See now what if I was smart, I would've
taken that idea and done it in Metropolis,
Illinois.
[laughter]
>> Male #16: Some big bang though, something
that draws a lot of attention to Superman
and then they start hearing about the book.
>> Larry: Getting the 17 foot Superman.
[laughter]
>> Male #17: I think it's, well, I mean, I
would go slightly simple route.
I would send a copy of your book to everyone
who writes a blog on Superman.
There are thousands.
>> Larry: So one of the things my smart editor
who said create buzz, he said as many names
as I could give him, he would send the book
out to.
So everybody every blogger and every website
person who has got one already they've been
extraordinarily helpful in doing it.
And we sent the day after we knew The New
York Times cover review was going to come
out and we knew that, the one thing that everybody
in old fashioned media like television does
is they read the Sunday New York times, that's
sort of guaranteed.
And so we had waiting on everybody from John
Stewart to Jay Leno and Letterman and everybody's
desk sort of the next day a copy that.
We've done everything.
But but there are a million other things and
I don't know what those things are and nobody
seems to know how to make it work.
>> Male #18: Sometimes I feel like there's
a common denominator the people who use social
media really effectively is that they do stuff
that's intrinsically interesting.
I'll give you a bite.
If I follow somebody on twitter and every
tweet is like "Buy my new book, buy my new
book, buy my new book", I'll probably unfollow
them, even if they might be an author who
I really like and respect, but if it's somebody
who actually creates a lot of interesting
additional content.
There's an author Maureen Johnson who I think
Twitter is doing pretty well.
And I wind up buying her books largely because
I find her Twitter feeds so consistently entertaining,
almost more entertaining than the books themselves.
>> Larry: Yes, that's a great idea and one
of the things that I'm doing is using a very
old fashioned form of media which is newspapers.
Somebody needed a room right there.
>> Male #19: We'll be a few more minutes.
>> Male #20: Alright, I'll wait.
>> Larry: So one of the things, if you're
ever, when you get your book done on angels
and demons, one of the things to realize,
old fashioned media can be exploited in a
brilliant way today, which is, everybody what
the op-ed page is in the newspaper.
Well, where all the columns are, and that
op-ed pages like most parts of newspapers
are actually being read today by more eyeballs
than ever in history.
They're just not being paid for because so
many people are reading it online.
But because newspapers are doing terribly
in terms of their economics and therefore
they can't most, op-ed pages can't afford
to pay for people to write for them anymore,
everybody's writing for them these days so
people like authors who are trying to, they've
got something there out there trying to promote.
So I've written every city I go to the publisher
sends me, I write an op-ed.
The Boston Globe ran a Superman op-ed strip
across their page with a brilliant graphic
that ensured that if for no other reason than
this brilliant picture people going to be
reading it.
And you're writing about everything that happens
in the world.
You're making hopefully a subtle link saying
that all these success of all these movies
this summer, Superman speaks to why those
why the Avengers was a big success.
You're trying to do all these things.
And I want to make one comment to you by the
way, if you are writing that book and you
seriously want to it, hook up before the book
is done, is it going to be a non fiction or
a fiction?
>> Male #16: Fiction
>> Larry: Fiction yes, show it to get an agent.
Boston had a lot of great book agents, more
than any city in America beyond New York and
maybe LA, Boston's a lot of them.
Before you get done with it you want to entice
an agent and a publisher into something so
that they think however much they're deceiving
themselves that they're part of shaping a
book, they love to think that.
[laughter] Angels and demons is a hot topic,
so get, think beyond just what you're writing
now to if you do want to sell this book someday.
Do you want to sell the book someday?
>> Male #16: Yeah [laughter]
>> Larry: Right well you'd like to get it
published.
So just get somebody involved with it.
Angels and demons is hot, make them see that
you get this and you got 50 pages or 25 pages
>> Male #16: It's pretty much written, I'm
kind of editing.
>> Larry: Then don't let them know that it's
all written.
[laughter] Just show it to them and whether
or not they become part of shaping is psychological,
the seeing it before it's done is important.
And the, and you've got enough to show.
Make the sure the pages that you show them,
somebody will only read, you have to write
the most brilliant five paragraph email that
you've ever done in your life to these agents
to get them interested enough to read the
first five or ten pages of the book.
You want to sort of entice them and you all
understand, you understand the people will
only read, you want to take them to each level.
So add them, write a brilliant email to them
and then send them the best five or ten pages
and then sit down and have lunch with them
and pick an agent that you think gets what
you are trying to do.
And do that soon.
>> Male #16: Yeah
>> Larry: Sorry
>> Male #21: If you have any chapters for
this book, you haven't put into this any one's
that fell on the cutting room floor.
Put them on your website.
>> Larry: That's a great idea.
And there are always, when you go out and
do a book tour, so I did my first book talk
on this book was at the Boston Public Library
and there was a guy who came into this book
talk, sitting in the back of the room and
the end when you are sort of done with questions,
he raises his hand and he says "Well, I have
a question, I've got a story I'd like to tell."
And this guy tells this story that when he
was growing up in New Jersey, one day his
dad was walking down the street in whatever
his home town was and Joe Shuster comes out
and taps the dad on the shoulder and says
"Excuse me, but you are my image of what Superman
ought to look like."
And this is twenty years after he wrote, drew
the first Superman, he said "Can I do a pencil
drawing of you?"
So the guy then takes out of his knapsack
at the Boston Public Library, two pencil drawings
that are the absolute spitting image of the
original Joe Shuster Superman and he says
"This is the first time I've ever taken these
out of my house and I thought they might be
interesting."
Well, those two pencil drawings, if you have
a copy, and I'm talking a copy of an issue
that 200,000 of which were the first Superman
comic book that is sold for more than a million
dollars.
This guy's pencil drawings are easily worth
many millions of dollars and this guy bringing
them out for the first time.
So you say write a chapter, I'd love to tell
all these stories about what sort of happens
to you as you are going along and those are
legitimate something and I got to find a blog
or somewhere that will Sort of get them.
Look, you've been great, somebody else gets
this room.
Thank you very much for coming and if you
want the book signed we can do that.
[Applause]